your album is out i i shouldn't be
telling you this and uh this is a jazz
album
wonderful i mean this is a very
accomplished musician as well as a great
actor i compliment you across the board
thank you
i love these pictures in here i mean
hey you know you may not know you know
where we shot those pictures i'm gonna
guess uh palm springs exactly right you
know whose house that is was that frank
sinatra's house i'm going to guess uh
harpo marx
i know harpo marx has a big fancy house
out there yeah yeah it's right
was it frank sinatra yes oh i'm just
guessing that frank sinatra famously had
an amazing house there so that's the
house i guess with the stage in the
middle of the pool no we put that
yeah no no we put that so uh you are a
great jazz player a lot of the classic
jazz players know how to scat when they
sing you know they is that something
that you know how to do i i imagine that
you would be able to scat i like
scattering a little bit i'll bet you are
good at it um here let's sing a song
well you show us some of your scatting i
just want to see you scattered
up
hey favorite
[Applause]
[Music]
that's you making fun of somebody
scouting i'm thinking like when ella
fitzgerald scouts you know it doesn't
sound there's not going to yeah yep yeah
yep yep yep
yep yep yep that was a what was that
that was the thing well what you just
did or what i did no what you were doing
what i did was a thing i learned from
the danny k did on a record that i heard
when i was a kid the great danny kaye
one of the great comedians of all time
yes you don't know nobody knows him here
holy ray
you do one there you go
the hell is your problem
this this woman's been waiting her whole
life
she's been going to tv tapings
for 30 years saying if they bring up
danny kaye
[Applause]
i want that woman
don't you wish
what is your name
ronnie
i wish ronnie was at the impeachment
trial right now
and i wish in the middle of the hearings
when they're all arguments
i know who danny k is
and it just tips the whole thing over
wouldn't that be fantastic yes
anyway back to our story the great danny
k
great danny k
used to scat he used to he used to
scatter well that he did that thing yeah
um let's get here i'll let's sing it so
do you know what song i'm saying i won't
sing the lyrics you do scatting is when
you don't do the lyrics is when you make
uh other sounds okay
and don't
adhere to the melody necessarily uh
[Music]
what song is that i can see clearly now
yeah yeah yeah i can see clearly now the
ring oh you don't want me to say the
name of the song
i want you to yeah then
then why did you look at me
you looked at me like either a i had
done something wrong or b you were in
love i didn't know
i am in love yeah
i'm sorry so what you want me to scat to
that is that what you ever wanted
that's everything we
great
wanted
when's the last time you sang that song
do you want anyone to know when the last
time i sang that song is i can't imagine
that it was there was two hours ago
and i'm not kidding i played it at
rehearsal that's one of the songs that
i've been obsessed with playing on the
guitar recently so i played it at
rehearsal because i love the bridge so
yes for you to bring up that song and
say when was the last time you sang that
song i mean it was psychic and it was
two hours ago well you're something we
don't know what but i don't know but
yeah it's true that's really crazy that
you brought that up isn't that crazy
yeah that is crazy
let's let it go with that